[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
day
[Music]
okay i'm gonna put figment up here since
i'm too short for the poor deep podium
anyway
all right so hi everyone
um i'm here today to take you on a
journey
into imagination um
i think my slides just cut out though
can you confirm that okay there we go
hdmi
old macbook it's fine cool so i'm going
to tell you a little bit about me first
my name is rachel white i'm the
developer experience lead
at american express which basically
means
it's my job to help improve the
developer
uh experience of learning and
interacting with our apis
internally so helping to fix
pipelines and make things easier for our
developers
whether you are an internal employee the
one that are building those or
if you're an external you know partner
and you're wanting to integrate with our
stuff
in addition to that i'm also on the
community committee for node.js
where we deal with the non-code side of
maintaining an open source project
so things like evangelism
internationalization
inclusivity the node website etc etc
and probably most importantly i care a
lot about
the creative thought processes
especially when it comes to programming
so this is going to be kind of a weird
talk which
is nothing new for me but this one's a
little more cute than weird
so as a little bit of a background also
i'm so excited to use the sparkle
transition
i've never gotten to do that before and
i felt like this was like the perfect
excuse to finally get to do it
anyway this is me i don't know how old i
am
probably like under seven
i don't understand children
so i've been to disney over 50 times i
grew up near disney world
and i've been going since before i could
even talk i have like some old home
videos of me when i was a baby
and my aunt is holding me and she's like
rachel look at look at mickey and my
foots in my mouth
so um but
the thing that i really like about it is
the immersive experience that you have
while you're in the park
and the kind of escape from reality that
it provided it was always like
really thrilling and really exciting to
me
and that probably correlates with my
love for tiki bars i just like
not being in the regular world
and whenever i couldn't go to the park
for a few years
and i'd visit again there would always
be something new to see
thanks to the imagineers and i started
thinking a lot about the experiences
that i had
as a child that helped shape me to who i
am today professionally
and realized that disney was a big part
of it and while yes i love disney world
i'm gonna tell you about the park that i
love even more
and that's epcot so
i fell in love with epcot the first
moment that i can remember
experiencing it which was in the late
80s epcot stands for the
experimental prototype community of
tomorrow
and there's two major parts of the park
the first one is
the world showcase and
the next one is future world
so epcot is dedicated to the celebration
of human achievement
namely technological innovation and
international culture
it's also often referred to as the
world's fair the world showcase has
11 sections representing different
countries
most people know about the world
showcase because that's one of the
places that everybody
that's over 21 goes to to get drunk in
the disney parks
but then future world is a variety of
pavilions that explore
innovative aspects and applications uh
including technology and science
and so while i could go on forever about
all of the things that i love about the
park in general we're going to focus on
one major part
and that's the imagination pavilion
which is why figment is here today
and why i decided to match him
so the imagination pavilion had to deal
with
imagination it was really colorful and
fun
inside and encouraged kids to be
creative and adults
associated with the imagination pavilion
we're the dream finder who is the
non-dragon
and figment who is the dragon
so the best part about the imagination
pavilion was a section inside called
image works
and it lasted from 1982 to
1988 i was born at the end of 1985 so
i'm surprised that i can still remember
some of this
there were things that you could
interact with like these
step tones where guests could create
music while by stepping on the different
lights and making different tones
and then there was also this coloring
book thing where you had
paint brushes and you could like paint
the colors and it all filled in
with light there were giant um touch pin
tables so
you know like those things that you can
put your face into and all the little
metal pins
it's it sounds gross when you think
about all the people touching it but
it was pretty cool um it was just really
really fun
and encouraged you to like do things
with technology but creatively
and inside the imagination pavilion was
a dark ride which is what
the rides in disney that are in the dark
are called who would have thought
it was called journey into imagination
and the inspiration for this talk
is where i got the name from so this one
lasted from 1983 until 1998
and in the ride the dream finder
introduces himself and says he uses the
dream mobile to collect dreams
and ideas to create all sorts of new
things
so then he creates a figment of his
imagination and
i wanted to show you some footage from
that ride i found from 1996
so you can experience the same thing i
got to as a child because this ride has
had
two other iterations after it and
they're bad
they're really bad so uh enjoy this
video it's two minutes and 30 seconds so
here we go
ideas anything that sparks the
imagination
can inspire amazing and marvelous
new ideas and you never know what kind
of figment you may come up with oh
here's my favorite two tiny wings
i speak in yellow horns of a steel
but a lovable fellow from head to tail
he's royal purple pigment
of childhood
of course imagination is something that
belongs to all of us
everyone can take up new
[Music]
so many times
[Music]
wow
foreign
no
all right so one thing this video also
shows is that people have been taking
bad video since before cell phones code
so
except it was just also like really big
and on your shoulder
so um after that part of the ride you go
through and
explore a bunch of different kind of
creative applications and they
talk about science too and they talk
about how scientists and like astronauts
and
using your creativity you can be
whatever you want and how
you know creativeness can apply to
anything
it doesn't just have to be like the arts
and i was like that's awesome
so the experiences that i had as a kid
with the imagination pavilion there's me
with the dream finder and figment i'm
sure it's not the same one
they look a little different but an
epcot's emphasis on technology
and feeling nostalgic for those moments
of exploration
led me to do a lot of research on the
things i loved about the park
so the blend of the education and the
creative learning and i wanted to know
more about how they did it
so i started reading up more about the
imagineers
and i found this quote from walt disney
that says there's really no secret about
our approach
we keep moving forward opening new doors
and doing new things
because we're curious and curiosity
keeps leading us down new paths
we're always exploring and experimenting
we call it imagineering
the blending of creative imagination and
technical knowledge so
imagineers are responsible for designing
and building disney theme parks
resorts cruise ships and other
entertainment venues
at all levels of project development so
they do the rides but they also do like
the interior of the restaurants to
the menu design it's everything everyone
is an imagineer
there's over 140 different job titles
that fall under the banner of
imagineering
including illustrators architects
engineers lighting designers
show writers graphic designers so all
these people that are multidisciplinary
they're all using the same principles
for when they create
i read a few books on imagineering and i
realized how perfect it was for what we
all do
every day um so i know that not everyone
likes disney and that's totally fine
what i think is the most important thing
from this is how successful
and how adaptable their model for
creating is and that's something
to learn from so why apply this to
software
you're probably like okay this is this
is for a theme park
but how can i possibly utilize this in
my day-to-day
and i'm gonna tell you don't worry i'm
not just gonna make you watch
vintage disney rides all day although
that would be fun for
me at least so basically from the moment
that you get in line for an attraction
at disney the imagineers know how to
keep you
captivated and shouldn't we be doing
that for the people that are using our
code
they're also responsible for crafting
your entire experience from start to
finish and making sure that you stay
engaged
and wouldn't you want someone that's
reading your documentation or going
through your demos to feel that way as
well
you don't want to lose their attention
in the middle of the important things
that you're telling them
so basically all of the imagineers
go by these mickey's ten commandments
and mickey's uh ten commandments were
created by
a legendary imagineer named marty sklar
and
they were from his experiences and
learnings early on in his 56 year career
at disney and they're basically the
basis for how
every imagineer tackles a project and i
think they're extremely helpful for our
own processes we talk a lot about
strategic thinking
or thinking like more technically and
this is
the opposite of that um they're all
centered around the experience of the
park goer
so for each of the ten commandments i'm
going to talk about disney's reasoning
behind it
and how i feel that we can all utilize
that
with our own users and our own code so
number one is know your audience number
two is wear your guest shoes
three is organize the flow of people and
ideas
four create a visual magnet five
communicate with visual literacy six
avoid overload seven tell one story at a
time
eight avoid contradictions maintain
identity
nine for every ounce of treatment
provide a ton of treat
and the easiest one for me to adapt to
programming
keep it up maintain it so
let's just jump right into it for the
first one
know your audience marty sclar wrote
that how you communicate and what you
communicate is totally influenced by who
you
identify as your target audience walt
disney started out planning for disney
by going to other amusement parks with
his daughters and sitting on a bench and
observing
seeing what what worked and what didn't
and he didn't start his vision for the
parks without
knowing who he was making it for
for us as engineers it's also important
to know our audiences
more well-established projects track
metrics and behaviors of their users
but that's already people that are using
a product so what can we do
to plan before we even write a piece of
code
if we have an idea for the end result
why don't we take a look at similar
projects or projects that you aspire to
be like
how do the users interact with it what
could you possibly do better
so this can be something like what
languages do they support in their apis
or
are we going to use npm or yarn
and someone who does this phantom
fantastically not someone
a project that does this fantastically
is nodebots so
um the way that they cater for every
single skill level
in their documentation makes the process
really fun and engaging so if you don't
know what you're doing
it's okay because they have the
documentation available so that you can
find the pieces that you need and piece
it together to like get what you need to
get done
they're aware that a lot of people that
are using nodebots are venturing into
hardware for the first time so they make
it easy for them to do that
but if you're somebody that's more you
know advanced
there they have a getter room where you
can chat
and harass them in the in a friendly way
to
get them to help you out not that i've
ever done that
number two is wear your guests shoes so
in disneyland's early years walt
insisted that every designer had to go
to the park
at least every other week and stand in
lines to understand
you know how the guests were
experiencing it
so when writing your documentation give
it to somebody else to try
see if it's written plainly enough and
accessible to all levels
appeal to more than just the senior
programmer the more open you are to all
levels of skill enables more adoption
for your project
more people will talk about it and
they'll encourage more people to use it
early on in my career i dealt a lot with
undocumented code bases
and documentation for libraries that
were too hard for me
to use because there wasn't a level of
thought and care put into it for the
user
since then i've told myself that i make
sure anything i have my hand in making
won't treat people the same
so here's an example of that this is
this is webpack um a poor example of
this in my opinion is what webpack has
on their landing page
webpack is a super important bundler
that a ton of people use
but i can't tell you the amount of times
that i've heard programmers say
i just don't get it or it's too hard so
it's that simple is really you know
not a great thing to say and i gave a
quick version of this talk at
brooklyn.js
as in i spoke as quickly as i could to
try and fit all of it in 10 minutes
and i went over but at the end of it jen
schiffer came up to me and was like
rachel stop being negative
which is true i should stop doing that
but she also told me that i should reach
out to sean larkin
and suggest to change it because it
would be way better case study than just
coming up here and being like
webpack is bad so i messaged him
and he was pumped he was totally chill
about it
he agreed with me they opened up a pull
request and are workshopping a better
title for that section
so don't be afraid to reach out to
maintainers with suggestions
for you know better language in a
project or suggestions for any kind of
improvements you're helping them
the next one is organize the flow of
people and ideas
so the important part of this is that
good stories and experiences have logic
and sequence that pay off for the time
and effort that the users put in
so put this care into your documentation
don't just give code samples and call it
a day
craft an experience for the users give
them a back story on when you built the
thing
and what you were trying to achieve with
its creation give them all of the
instruction and the tools they need to
provision their machine before even
getting to the code that you wrote
include a section with a link to
commonly encountered errors or issues
that people have
each step along the way will set them up
for success
a company that does this fantastically
is twilio when you sign up for their
services
during the sign up process they ask you
what language is your primary language
and then when you're done with the sign
up and you're going to their projects
the things that you're looking up are
already there in the language that
you're looking for so you don't have to
go digging for it and that's great
the next one is create a visual magnet
so disney has visual magnets throughout
the park
and they draw you in from a distance to
a specific part so cinderella's castle
the rocket ship in tomorrowland space
earth and epcot they serve as a visual
line but also a point of reference for
park goers so
you can coordinate meet up plans with
these visual targets and everybody knows
what you're talking about
so in programming one way that you can
do this is by being unique with your
demos
create something exciting for people to
build while learning to how
while learning how to use your code
it'll definitely stick out more than
giving them
a generic hello world or a to-do list
somebody that does this fantastically is
wes boss
the react for beginners course you build
a really fun seafood ordering and
inventory page
it's different and it like grabs your
attention
and it helped explain props and states
super well
it's one of my favorite resources to use
whenever i need to go back and like
refresh react stuff which is all the
time because i have a terrible memory
and i can associate the things that i
learned from him with each unique step
of the tutorial that i went through
which is
really memorable and important
the next one is communicate with visual
literacy so
imagineers use a ton of non-verbal ways
to communicate
in order to be an effective communicator
make sure that you take advantage of the
non-verbal tools you have at your deman
at your command
so how is your documentation is it all
just sample code
what could you do in order to improve
the user's experience
so many people that are coming into
programming are coming from
non-traditional computer science
backgrounds or are changing their jobs
later in life
they're coming in as visual learners and
they need diagrams and
drawings and cartoons to grasp concept
concepts that might be new to them
so use them and somebody who does this
great
is lynn clark so lynn's code cartoons
are super helpful and they explain a lot
of concepts
really visually and it just helps it
make sense versus reading an article
about redux which who
who wants to do that
so the next one is avoid overload
when imagineers take on a new project
they learn as much as they can about the
story assignment but then
their second task is to reduce all that
to what's important
so you want to have a lot of information
in your documentation
but you need to structure it well don't
just have one really long page going to
all of the information
surrounding the api break it up into
different parts
one section for getting started another
for an api reference another one for
code snippets
a company that does this fantastically
is stripe their documentation is really
clean and organized
you know where to go exactly where you
need to go for when you need it
they don't overload you with too much
information at the get-go and they don't
overwhelm you
the next one is tell one story at a time
stick to the story line
good stories are clear logical and
consistent
disney invented the storyboard in the
1930s which i didn't know about before i
started this research which was cool
and the whole point of it is to create a
storyline that holds together from end
to end
it's to create a clear story that they
can review with anyone even if they're
not involved in the process and they'll
be able to understand it
so storyboard your documentation as well
think of where you want the user to
start out and at the end what knowledge
you want them to come out that they
didn't have at the beginning
if it's just an api reference that's one
thing but
for something more technically written
perhaps come up with a scenario and tell
it that way
case studies and user stories are also a
fantastic thing to use for this
oh was that a double slide sorry about
that oh wait
storyboard
that was double okay
sorry about that um the next one is tell
one story at a time which i should have
taken
for this talk because i just got
confused um
oh wait no i see what's happening that
went double
okay here we go ah keynote
listen i worked on a windows machine for
the last year and a half
i'm getting used to this again
okay here we go somebody that does this
really well is d3
so while not being the like cleanest of
the presentation of examples
they have a whole section of real world
implementations of d3 being used which
is really helpful
because you can see the source and find
parts that you can implement into your
own projects
and a lot of libraries don't take
advantage of this and it really is the
easiest way to show somebody
implementations that they can take and
build off from to just get started
really quickly
because sometimes a working real example
of code is better than snippets that
they can just piece together
the next one is avoid contradictions
details and
the design details of disney's main
street is friendly and complimentary
the city hall doesn't conflict with the
opera house nothing is screaming out
with you for attention
the graphics are equal in representation
you know where you are
and the details make for a really
pleasant experience
so leave out the details of wants and
things that didn't work out in your
documentation
keep only the positive messages
sometimes people explain hardships that
they experienced while making something
or something that they wanted to do or
didn't get to
i'm guilty of doing that before just
leave it out don't include negativity
unless it's something that you actually
learned from and there's a lesson there
so one of those good things is no
to-do's and read me's
make them issues instead so people that
want to get involved with your project
can see it
and see the things that need to get done
and just don't talk about
the things that went wrong so next
is for every ounce of treatment provide
a ton of treat
disney educates but they don't tell you
that they're doing so
they let you discover and learn but
while being surrounded by fun and
excitement
um so i gave a talk last year at
jsconfeu about learning how to program
uh like in sites before stack overflow
and hacker news where
uh they gamified knowledge sharing and
how much more fun it was then
try and go back to the feeling that you
had when you were first learning how to
code
and the excitement of learning something
new and try and add that magic and fun
into your project
somebody who does this perfectly is
sailor hg
amy makes these amazing and fun cute
super informative scenes about computer
science concepts through
creative projects they're really
engaging and they keep you interested in
and the last but probably the most
important
commandment is keep it up maintain it
disney is spotless and since it's kept
so clean the guests inherently also keep
it clean
not wanting to contribute trash to an
otherwise nice looking area
without thinking about it you're wanting
to find the nearest trash can so that
you don't contribute
anything bad to a spotless park the
rides are always well maintained and
that takes a ton of effort
if everything wasn't functioning the way
it intended it wouldn't be the same
disney experience
so the same principles go for our code
maintain it pay attention to the users
don't ignore pull requests or people
that are eager to contribute
iterate as you learn more and make it
better and i know that's hard
for really big projects so just try and
keep that as a basis for
everyone that's involved to just like
you know check in every once in a while
and see if there's
people in there that are wanting to help
so yeah
check these things i'm not saying what
project this is for
it's big anyway
so basically what i'm trying to say is
a creative thinking process is
beneficial to technical material
it allows us to reach more people than
we would if we stick to dry
documentation with a lot of technical
jargon
putting care and attention into tracking
all of your potential
users will make your project better in
the long run
so a lot of my research for this talk
came from this book
which is one little spark it goes over
all of the ten commandments and
tells you about how they apply to the
disney parks and how imagineers use them
in practice it's really interesting if
you want to check it out
and if you like what i had to say today
or if you want to yell at me
i don't know you can find me a couple
places
i am oho on twitter i've also been
streaming coding content on twitch every
monday
friday and sunday at 4 pm eastern 1 pm
pacific
we're starting where i i started with
free code camp so i started all the way
at html
and i'm going to make my way all the way
to infosec which i know nothing about
and i'm just streaming to try and like
show other developers that vulnerability
is okay
i had a test go wrong when i was trying
to write a horizontal rule tag and i was
like okay
i know i know what a horizontal rule is
there's no way that there's something
wrong here and i had to live like
search free code camp test broken and i
was right and i was like
i knew i was right um i'm also going to
be creating
fun videos on youtube of programming and
hardware for non-programmers so like
cosplayers hobbyists stuff like that and
i'm calling both of these what the help
because it's cute and i'm also
on drip which is kickstarter's um like
patreon like
platform uh this was journey into
imagination
i'm rachel white thank you
[Applause]